♪ ♪
>> Translator: THE DISCUSSIONS
WE'VE HAD TOGETHER MAKE IT
POSSIBLE TO OPEN THE WAY COME UP
PAVE THE WAY FOR A NEW
AGREEMENT, AN AGREEMENT ON WHICH
WE WILL WORK.
BEYOND OUR EUROPEAN PARTNERS.
>> IT SEES SENSUAL THAT THE
RESPONSIBLE NATIONS OF THE
MIDDLE EAST STEP UP THEIR OWN
CONTRIBUTIONS TO PREVENT IRAN
FROM PROFITING OFF THE SUCCESS
OF OUR ANTI-ISIS EFFORTS.
THEY HAVE TO STEP UP
TREMENDOUSLY.
NOT A LITTLE BIT BUT
TREMENDOUSLY THEIR FINANCIAL
EFFORT.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
THE FRENCH PRESIDENT TODAY
TAKING QUESTIONS, TALKING A LOT
ABOUT THE IRAN DEAL.
THE PRESIDENT CALLING IT A
DECAYING FOUNDATION.
THE DEAL HAS A DECAYING
FOUNDATION, AND WANTS A NEW
DEAL.
YOU HEARD THAT FROM THE FRENCH
PRESIDENT AS WELL.
THEY TALKED ABOUT SYRIA AND
OBVIOUSLY OUT OF THAT PRESS
CONFERENCE, A LOVE NEWS ABOUT
THE VA SECRETARY NOMINATION.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT WITH THE PANEL.
TOM BEVAN, REAL CLEAR POLITICS.
MARA LIASSON, NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
AT "THE FEDERALIST."
LET'S START WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL STUFF.
NEWS ON THE IRAN SITUATION.
CLEARLY THEY HAVE A PERSONAL
RAPPORT, THESE TWO.
THERE WERE AIR KISSES.
>> FLICKING DANDRUFF OFF
SHOULDERS.
>> Bret: THEY ALSO SEEM TO
HAVE, OR CI TIE EVEN THOUGH
THERE ARE DIFFERENCES, ON MOVING
FORWARD WITH SOMETHING NEW.
>> SOMETHING NEW.
MACRON WORKED REALLY, REALLY
HARD TO SELL TRUMP ON THIS IDEA
OF USING THE IRAN DEAL AS A
FOUNDATION AND BUILDING ON IT,
AUNTIE CAME ABOUT WITH THREE
PILLARS THAT WOULD ADDRESS
TRUMP'S CONCERNS.
IN ADDITION TO STOPPING IRAN
FROM DEVELOPING NUCLEAR WEAPONS
IN TEN YEARS WHICH THE CURRENT
AGREEMENT DOES, YOU WOULD ADD ON
SOMETHING THAT WOULD KEEP THEM
FROM DOING IT PERMANENTLY.
BALLISTIC MISSILES, STOPPING
THEM FROM INTERFERING IN YEMEN
AND SYRIA AND IRAQ.
HE WANTS TO USE THE EXISTING
AGREEMENT IS THE FOUNDATION.
TRUMP WAS TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT STARTING A
WHOLE NEW FOUNDATION.
I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW IT
WORKS IF ON MAY 12, AS I THINK
TRUMP HINTED TODAY, HE WANTS TO
SCRAP THE DEAL.
>> Bret: YEAH, MOLLIE.
>> IN ADDITION TO THOSE
PROBLEMS, HE DOESN'T LIKE THE
DEAL BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
ABILITY TO INSPECT THE PROGRAM
AND THE INABILITY TO DEAL WITH
BALLISTIC MISSILES.
HIS IDEA THAT THIS IS JUST A BAD
DEAL AT THE OUTSET, THAT GREEN
LET THE NUCLEAR PROGRAM AND
DOESN'T MATCH OUR INTEREST.
IT MAKES SENSE EUROPE LIKES THIS
PROGRAM.
IT MAKES SENSE THEY SEE SOME
GOOD IN BEING ABLE TO TRADE WITH
IRAN AND THE STABILITY THE DEAL
GAVE IRAN AND EUROPE, BUT IT
DOESN'T MATCH THE U.S. INTEREST.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
CAME THROUGH THE PRESS
CONFERENCE, THE DISCUSSION ABOUT
MAKING SURE THINGS ARE IN THE
NATIONAL INTEREST.
I WAS STRUCK BY WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID WE SPEND
$17 TRILLION, OR $7 TRILLION IN
THE MIDDLE EAST AND SPENT 17
YEARS THERE.
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT TO SHOW FOR
IT.
HE IS ASKING FOR REGIONAL ALLIES
TO STEP UP AND DOING WHAT'S IN
THEIR INTEREST RATHER THAN US
BANKROLLING EVERYTHING WITH
MONEY AND SOLDIERS.
>> Bret: IT ALSO FACTORS IN
WITH SYRIA.
HERE'S AN EXCHANGE WITH THE
LEADERS ON SYRIA.
>> AS FAR AS SYRIA IS CONCERNED,
I WOULD LOVE TO GET OUT.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, EMMANUEL
AND MYSELF HAVE DISCUSSED THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T WANT TO GIVE
IRAN OPEN SEASON TO THE
MEDITERRANEAN.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO BE COMING
HOME RELATIVELY SOON.
>> WHEN YOU ARE PROBABLY MUCH
MORE AT THE END OF OR COMING UP
TO ADAPT TO THE ENEMY REALITY ON
THE GROUND.
WHAT WE WANT TO DO NOW IS FINISH
WITH OUR TROOPS AND WE WANT TO
FIX ON THE LONG RUN, THE
SITUATION.
>> Bret: TOM, THOUGHTS ON
THAT.
OBVIOUSLY DIFFERENCES.
SEEMS LIKE THEY'VE COME TOGETHER
ON THAT TOO.
>> CORRECT.
TRUMP WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW WELL
THEY WORKED TOGETHER, WHAT A
SUCCESS IT WAS, THE SYRIA
STRIKE.
CLEARLY HE WANTS TO BE OUT OF
SYRIA.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO GO BACK THERE
IN THE SLIGHTEST.
TRUMP WILL BE PUTTING PRESSURE,
AS MOLLIE SAID COME ON FRANCE
AND OTHER ALLIES TO STEP UP AND
MAKE SURE THERE'S A SOLUTION IN
SYRIA THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
WITHDRAW BECAUSE HE HAS WANTED
THAT FOR A LONG, LONG TIME.
ONE OF HIS ORIGINAL CAMPAIGN
PROMISES.
>> Bret: BIG FOCUS TODAY ENDED
UP BEING THE VETERANS AFFAIRS
SECRETARY NOMINATION OF RONNY
JACKSON.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
HEARING AND ANSWERING EVERYONE'S
QUESTIONS.
>> I HAVEN'T HEARD OF THE
PARTICULAR ALLEGATIONS BUT I
WILL TELL YOU HE'S ONE OF THE
FINEST PEOPLE THAT I HAVE MET.
I KNOW THERE IS AN EXPERIENCE
PROBLEM BECAUSE LACK OF
EXPERIENCE.
I WOULD EVIDENTLY SAY HE'S A
FINE MAN.
I WILL ALWAYS STAND BEHIND HER.
I WOULD LET IT BE HIS CHOICE.
>> Bret: AS OF TONIGHT, THE
WHITE HOUSE SAYING THEY ARE
STANDING BEHIND HIM AND HE IS
GOING TO CONTINUE FORWARD WITH
THE NOMINATION.
>> INTERESTING HEARING THE
PRESIDENT TALK THAT WAY BECAUSE
IT SEEMED LIKE HE WAS GIVING HIM
A WAY OUT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO PUT UP WITH
THAT, YOU CAN GET OUT.
GET DR. JACKSON SAYS HE'S
ABSOLUTELY INTENT ON GOING
THROUGH THE HEARINGS WHICH
SUGGEST ALSO THAT WE MIGHT NEED
TO LEARN A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
WHAT THESE ALLEGATIONS ARE.
ARE THEY A DISGRUNTLED FORMER
COLLEAGUE TALKING?
OR IS THERE SOMETHING LEGITIMATE
THERE.
THE FACT THAT SO MANY
ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE WORKED WITH
HIS DOCTOR AND PRAISED HIM IN SO
MANY PEOPLE SING HIS PRAISES
REGARDLESS OF POLITICAL
AFFILIATION, IT SAID SOMETHING.
THE ISSUE IS, AGAIN I THINK THE
ISSUE PEOPLE SHOULD FOCUS ON IS
WHETHER BEING A GOOD DOCTOR AND
BEING BELOVED BY THESE
ADMINISTRATIONS MEANS YOU CAN
HANDLE THE VERY SERIOUS PROBLEMS
AT THE VA.
>> Bret: THAT'S THE REAL
QUESTIONS FOR VETERANS GROUPS.
SECOND LARGEST AGENCY, 370,000
WORKERS.
STICK A ONE OF THE BIGGEST
HEALTH SYSTEMS IN AMERICA.
>> Bret: THAT IS REALLY THE
QUESTION.
THE STATEMENT FROM
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
PRESIDENT BUSH TELL IT TO THE
CHARACTER OF DR. JACKSON AND HIS
ABILITY.
>> HE IS TREATED THE STAFFS ON
THE PRESIDENTS, THEY LOVE HIM.
THE COMPLAINTS APPARENTLY THAT
OF GONE TO A COMMITTEE OR STAFF
AND PROBLEMS THERE.
>> Bret: THERE WAS AN INTERNAL
DISPUTE AGAINST AN OPPONENT.
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE TRUE.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THE WHITE HOUSE
WAS AWARE OF THEM.
>> Bret: IT HASN'T PREVENTED
CAPITOL HILL FROM OUT ALL KINDS
OF STUFF.